-Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show"!
You're here. You made it.
Thank you for being here.
Thank you for watching.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Well, guys, Pfizer and Moderna
both say
that they're already working
on vaccines
for the Omicron variant.
While Johnson & Johnson
is cheering them on.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Yeah, Johnson & Johnson is like,
"Guys, I thought we promised
we're not doing vaccines
this year.
[ Laughter ]
Why would you embarrass me?"
How'd they start working on this
so fast, too?
It's like when a team
wins the Super Bowl
and the first commercial is,
"Buy your
Buccaneers Championship
hat now!"
[ Laughter ]
You're like, "Wait."
Meanwhile, officials
just announced
that Omicron was present
in Amsterdam 11 days ago.
[ Audience oohs ]
It took a while to catch it
because, in Amsterdam,
there's a very different meaning
to "a new strain going around."
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Clears throat ]
Yeah.
Certain sections of our audience
got that faster
[ Laughter and applause ]
than others.
Yeah, following the news
on the Omicron variant,
the CDC is now saying
that all adults
should get a booster shot.
Right now, Instagram is like,
"Incoming booster selfies
in 3, 2, 1!"
[ Laughter ]
Well, guys,
tomorrow's December 1st
and everyone's starting
to decorate for the holidays,
so, the FAA
is warning people not
to shine laser light displays
into the sky.
[ Laughter ]
The pilots are actually fine
with the lasers.
It's the emotional support cats
onboard that go nuts.
[ Laughter ]
They're just like --
[ Applause ]
Well, this is cool --
Roomba updated
its latest vacuum cleaner
so that they use AI
to avoid knocking over
Christmas trees.
[ Laughter ]
But don't worry --
with the new update,
your Roombas will still inhale
the tree skirt,
until it blows up
and burns your house down.
[ Laughter ]
It was kind of weird
when the Roomba
kept knocking over the
Christmas tree and then going --
[ Robotic voice ]
Hanukkah rules.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, I saw that a new study said
that babies start to develop
a sense of humor
after one month.
It's pretty obvious
when your baby's like --
[ As Jerry Seinfeld ]
What's the deal with naps?
[ Laughter ]
What am I so tired from?
All I did before this
was sleep!
[ Laughter ]
Soft foods, wearing diapers,
napping before sleep --
I'm turning into Grandpa!
[ Laughter ]
I wrote a full-on Seinfeld
-Wow.
Fantastic.
-stand-up act as a baby, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Get this -- I read that,
this year, in America,
210 million packages
have already been stolen.
[ Audience oohs ]
Yeah, it turns out
those Ring doorbells
were a lot more effective
before everyone started
wearing masks.
[ Laughter ]
It's like, "Uh, yes,
two humans?
I don't know.
Does that help you, Officer?
It wasn't a coyote that took
the package, yeah."
[ Laughter ]
Finally, police in Germany
are looking for burglars
who broke through the wall
of a toy store
to steal dozens of LEGO sets.
The store was like,
"Ah, maybe we shouldn't have
built that wall with DUPLOs."
[ Laughter ]
The thieves got away,
but said their one regret was
robbing the place barefoot.
Ow!